Boa noite a todos prazer estar novamente
com vocês vão me dando um feedback se o
áudio tá legal se vocês me ouvem bem boa
noite Darling Boa noite
Carlos já tem uma pergunta aqui eu vou
já responder antes de começar analisar
os artigos que eu separei para hoje
queria saber se tem no Brasil clínicas
ou pediatras que usem monodoses e
calendários alternativos no PNI como
opção as vacinas do serviço
público existem pessoas que têm clínicas
de vacina
particulares agora se vão utilizar
calendário alternativo eu não sei te
dizer viu esse é o tipo
de situação que eu não tô muito a p
porque não trabalho muito com
ação mas se
eu ficar sabendo eu te aviso tá mas
realmente eu não tenho esse conhecimento
Boa noite
Eliane Bem pessoal vamos aqui discutir
uns artigos interessantes e depois a
gente vai responder à perguntas do
documento tá primeiro artigo é sobre
análise da carne vermelha a sua relação
com mortalidade então foi efetuado um
estudo muito interessante utilizando
usando uma análise nova chamada se
análise multiversa já vou explicar o que
que é isso bem sabemos que no campo da
Saúde na nutrição poucos temas geram
tanto debate quanto o assunto né do
consumo da carne vermelha que muita
gente considera carne vermelha como algo
não saudável Então ela é
tradicionalmente associado tanto a
benefícios né Por ter vários nutrientes
como vitamina B12 carnosina
carnitina entre outros
quanto a riscos para a saúde né muita
gente acha que pode gerar riscos à
saúde então por isso a carne vevera tem
sido objeto de estudos variados ao longo
dos anos e recentemente houve Esse
estudo novo uma abordagem inovadora
chamado análise multiversa para tentar
esclarecer essa questão Então
vamos vamos mergulhar nos detalhes e
explicações dessa metodologia e vamos
ter uma nova perspectiva sobre o impacto
do consumo da carne vermelha na
mortalidade tá então A análise
multiversa é uma técnica emergente que
permite aos pesquisadores explorar uma
gama extensa de métodos analíticos em um
único conjunto de dados Então isso é
feito para identificar como diferentes
abordagens podem influenciar os
resultados de estudos observacionais
então a chamada análise de curva de
especificação é uma dessas técnicas onde
os dados são analisados so milhares de
perspectivas distintas para revelar qual
delas mais se aproxima da verdade então
eles pegam várias análises estatísticas
diferentes e rodam paralelamente uma a
outra para gerar um um conjunto muito
grande de dados que depois são
consolidados a aplicação dessa técnica
no estudo do consumo da carne vermelha e
da mortalidade mostrou uma variação
significativa nos resultados Enquanto
algumas sugeriram uma redução de até 50%
no risco de mortalidade precoce para
consumidores de carne vermelha outras
indicaram aumento de risco de até 75%
veja como tá dispare né alguns estudos
falam que reduz em até 50% o risco de
mortalidade precoce e outros dizem que
aumenta o risco em 75% Então veja a
confusão no entanto a maior parte das
análises cerca de
64% concluiu que o consumo de carne
vermelha não tem Impacto significativo
na
mortalidade trazendo uma luz sobre o
possível exagero das evidências que
sugerem um grande risco associado ao
consumo então o estudo destacou o
problema das pesquisas observacionais
que muitas vezes publicam Apenas
resultados que mostram associações
significativas ignorando análises que
apresentam resultados nulos ou
contraditórios então isso pode levar a
uma visão
distorcida e potencialmente alarmista
sobre certos comportamentos ou consumos
alimentares então a adoção dessa análise
multiversa que é uma novidade na
estatística porque também é uma coisa
que envolve muita capacidade
computacional que só tá sendo possível
hoje em dia né na era do Big Data essa
análise ela é recomendada para aprimorar
a precisão e a confiabilidade dos
estudos observad ionais especialmente em
Campos como a epidemiologia nutricional
Então essa abordagem não apenas fornece
uma visão mais abrangente sobre os dados
como também democratiza as escolhas
analíticas mostrando que o Consenso
entre múltiplos métodos analíticos que
deve ser utilizado né ele pode ser mais
informativo do que a dependência de um
único método acho isso aqui muito
interessante tá explicando de uma forma
mais simples para vocês tá métodos
analíticos diversos né a pesquisa
utilizou muitos métodos diferentes para
analisar os dados sobre o consumo da
carne vermelha e sua relação com a
mortalidade isso é importante porque
diferentes maneiras de analisar os
mesmos dados podem levar a conclusões
diferentes então resultados variados
sobre a carne vermelha nos estudos com
relação à mortalidade as conclusões do
estudo variaram muito né então em alguns
casos os resultados mostraram que o b
carne vermelha poderia diminuir o risco
da Morte precoce quanto em outro
aumentava o risco então a maior parte
das análises no entanto indicou que não
há um impacto significativo do consumo
de carne vermelha na
mortalidade então só para ficar mais
claro aindo para vocês A análise
multiversa geralmente envolve uma
intensa capacidade
isso se deve ao grande número de
análises que são realizadas para avaliar
os mesmos dados sobre diferentes
perspectivas e métodos
estatísticos então no estudo da carne
vermelha foram consideradas cerca de
1200 maneiras 1200 maneiras diferentes
de analisar os dados o que exige um
processamento computacional considerável
para realizar todas essas análises de
forma eficiente em um tempo
razoável certo
Então esse é o primeiro estudo que eu
queria discutir com vocês se ficou
alguma dúvida sobre o que eu falei se
ficar por favor coloque a sua pergunta
aí na no
bate-papo Boa noite Eliseu e boa noite
TAM
miquinha próximo estudo é sobre o azeite
de oliva e a prevenção da
demência o título desse artigo é azeite
de oliva e prevenção de demência entre
mitos e Evidências científicas então nós
sabemos que no universo da nutrição tem
muitos assuntos que são polêmicos e que
são controversos que conclusões muito
diferentes de um estudo pro outro então
poucos temas são tão debatidos quanto os
benefícios do azeite de oliva então
recentemente foi publicado um estudo no
jama que é o Journal of American Medical
Association que lançou novas luzes sobre
o potencial do azeite de oliva em
reduzir o risco de morte relacionado à
demência então Nesse artigo Eh vamos
mergulhar na as nuances explorar as
implicações e desvendar até que ponto
podemos
confiar então o Dr Perry Wilson da
escola de medicina de e né proporcionou
uma análise crítica sobre essa questão
desse artigo do azeite de
oliva que vincula o consumo do azeite de
oliva a uma menor incidência de mortes
por demência o estudo é grande Ele
acompanhou quase 100.000 pessoas 100.000
Profissionais de Saúde que estavam
tratando pacientes com demência ao longo
de duas décadas utilizando questionários
frequentes sobre hábitos alimentares
Então quais foram os principais achados
né os participantes que consumiram mais
de 7 g de azeite por dia mostraram cerca
de 50% menos chances de morrer por
demência em comparação com aqueles que
não consumiram o
azeite porém H desafios na análise dos
dados a interpretação dos resultados de
estudos nutricionais muitas vezes Barra
em vários desafios
metodológicos existe a questão do viés
alimentar né aqueles que consumiram
azeite também provavelmente adotaram uma
dieta geralmente mais saudável rica em
frutas vegetais e grãos integrais e
Pobre em carnes vermelhas e margarinas
né que são ruins você sab que elas têm
gorduras trans T gorduras intericad
Inter esterificados então isso Levanta a
questão os benefícios são realmente do
azeite ou do padrão ali mentar como todo
né esse que é o fator
confundidoras isso porque essa pessoa
tem vários hábitos aado de vida melhor
ainda né mas para em termos estatísticos
de você isolar um elemento pode ser um
problema e tem também uma influência
socioeconômica o azeite de oliva ele é
mais caro do que os outros
olhos isso sugere que seu consumo pode
estar associado a um padrão de vida mais
alto né um padrão só econômico mais
elevado que geralmente as pessoas que
estão nesse patamar T acesso a melhores
condições de saúde e hábitos mais
saudáveis
né Então existe um estudo anterior
chamado predimed que foi realizado na
Espanha também Ele oferece uma defesa ao
azeite nesse ponto aí nesse estudo
controlado os participantes que
receberam azeite regularmente tiveram
uma redução de 30% nos cardiovasculares
uma diminuição de
65% na taxa de desenvolvimento de
comprometimento cognitivo leve então o
estudo Inicial falava em 50% e esse aqui
o PR médio fala em
65% então eu recomendo fortemente que
vocês utilizem um azeite de oliva de
alta
qualidade que
seja de baixa acidez e também extra
virgem como parte uma diet associada mas
não deve considerá-los como um Elixir
milagroso Ok tem que ser associado a
outras medidas de estilo de vida como a
gente sempre fala nos vídeos
né bem o último artigo para discutir
hoje é em relação o impacto do tempo de
tela na saúde psicológica das crianças o
que os pais precisam saber vários de
vocês podem ter filhos ainda pequenos ou
conhecem alguém que tem filho pequeno o
dentro da própria família né então
devemos ter preocupações constantes com
o bem-estar psicológico das Crianças em
relação ao tempo de tela Isso tem sido
muito discutido é um tema muito atual e
tem muitas dúvidas sobre esse tema então
Muitos pais discutem sobre isso
educadores também profissionais da Saúde
então o estudo recente traz novas
perspectivas sobre como o tempo Diário
de enfrente as telas pode influenciar a
saúde mental de crianças pequenas
destacando a necessidade de um
equilíbrio cuidadoso entre tempo de tela
e outras atividades então o estudo em
questão é o consumo de tempo de tela ele
analisou como tempo Diário de tela está
associado ao bem-estar psicológico das
Crianças usando dados coletados durante
os anos antes da pandemia e durante a
mesma o estudo
observacional contou com quase 50.000
crianças e focou em dois grupos etários
principais crianças de 6 meses a 2 anos
e de 3 a 5 anos
então houve uma influência negativa do
tempo de tela nas crianças de 3 a 5 anos
que passavam mais de Du horas por dia em
frente às telas né e tinham maior
probabilidade de ter comportamentos
externos negativos como hiperatividade
agressividade e menores índices de
comportamento desenvolvimento como afeto
e curiosidade e curiosamente não teve um
efeito notável em bebês e crianças
pequenas então na faixa de 6 meses a 2
anos o tempo de tela não foi associado a
uma relação
significativa com índices de
desenvolvimento
alterado então a pandemia de
2019 né ampliou o uso do tempo de tela
entre as crianças né que ficaram
confinadas nos anos de 2020 e 2021 com
variações significativas observadas
entre diferentes grupos socioeconômicos
raciais e étnicos
Então esse estudo destaca a complexidade
do impacto do tempo de tela sobre o
desenvolvimento infantil não é apenas a
quantidade de tempo em frente às telas
que importa Mas também o contexto no
qual Esse tempo é
inserido então o tipo de atividade
realizada durante esse tempo de tela
seja Educacional Recreativo pode
influenciar de maneiras distintas o
desenvolvimento infantil programas
educativos interativos são
recomendados podem oferecer benefícios
ao desenvolvimento de habilidades
sociais e cognitivas e especialmente em
crianças maiores de 2
anos é importante equilibrar o tempo de
tela com atividades físicas interação
Face a Face fundamentais pro
desenvolvimento saudável das Crianças
Então quais são as diretrizes para pais
e cuidadores com base nessa descoberta
do estudo eh recomendável que pais e
cuidadores limitem o tempo de tela eh
seguir as diretrizes da academia
americana de Pediatria que recomenda no
máximo uma hora por dia de tela para
criança de 2 a 5 anos e evitar o uso de
telas em geral exceto para videochamadas
para crianças menores de 2
anos priorizar como eu já falei
conteúdos educativos interativos que
promovam aprendizado e Desenvolvimento
Social incen atividades em família que
não envolvam tela como leitura jogos
atividades ao ar livre né então isso é
importante que nós tenhamos em mente
bem Vamos às
dúvidas do documento
Ah deixa eu voltar aqui
para primeira
pergunta pergunta do Carlos
kman Boa noite muitos produtos
problemáticos da Saúde se tornam
recomendáveis quando
fermentados Quais são as alterações
benéficas que o Proc
produz presença ou contaminação com
hormônios produtos químicos Como o
polifluor
po fluoro alquil pfa podem ser
degradados e inutilizados pergunta bem
PK essa aqui viu mas parabéns pela
pergunta
bastante inteligente
tá bem o processo de alimentação ele tem
vários características aí que vão
melhorar o alimento né é um processo
metabólico que vai transformar
substâncias complexas em compostos mais
simples e é mediado com microorganismos
que são bactérias leveduras e fungos
Então vai aumentar a biodisponibilidade
de vários
nutrientes vai produzir compostos
bioativos como ácidos orgânicos enzimas
e substâncias que podem ajudar na
metabolismo que tem propriedades
antimicrobianas e antioxidantes melhora
a
digestibilidade Por exemplo quando você
fermenta o leite você vai degradar a
lactose do leite Isso vai tornar ele
mais digerível reduz os antinutrientes
porque destrói também os fitatos os
oxalatos processo de
eh fermentação e produz também
substâncias interessantes pela ação ah
bacteriana que ajuda na digestão como eu
já falei e também pode fortalecer o
sistema de defesa imune agora em relação
a pergunta dos
pfa não tem evidências Claras que existe
algum microrganismo aí comumente
encontrado nos produtos fermentados que
vai conseguir destruir tá esse produto
químico aí então Eh isso não é uma coisa
que dá para confiar
eles até descobriram alguns
microrganismos que podem degradar
hormônios
estrogênicos mas não é claro ainda que
esse caso aí o pfa é um elemento que
consegue
ser destruído através da ação microbiana
dos probióticos Ok então não confie
nisso viu
Carlos vamos pra
próxima ruel poder indicar um
cardiologista especializado em ritmia da
linha integrativa Eu só conheço um
cardiologista para integrativo tá
poderia dar dois nomes aqui mas vou dar
só um porque o outro não é muito
integrativo não é só propaganda tá Eu
recomendo o Túlio
Sperb Ok então o Túlio Sperb Vou colocar
aqui na
tela ele não é ritmologia que eu saibo
mas é um cardiologista integrativo
Ok próxima
[Música]
pergunta a progesterona pode ser
utilizada sem usar o
estrogênio ela sozinha traz benefício
Sim ela pode ser utilizada isoladamente
isso acontece muitas vezes tá por
exemplo mulheres na fase ainda que
menstruam né que estão
ainda férteis ela pode ser usada
isoladamente para os ciclos menstruais e
mulheres T ciclos irregulares tá para
poder ajudar na ovulação pode ser
utilizada isoladamente também para
tratar síndrome pré-menstrual né o
famoso
TPM pode ser utilizado para hiperplasia
endometrial para reduzir o espessamento
do endométrio no
útero pode ser utilizado durante a
gravidez para dar suporte a gravidez né
para segurar a
gravidez pode ser utilizado até para
questões de trauma ano tá trauma
cerebral A progesteron tem uns estudos
que ela teve efeito protetor contra o
trauma e pode ser utilizado isoladamente
também em mulheres tem endometriose como
tratamento com
endometriose e a sua variação que a
adenomiose agora para reposição hormonal
você deve utilizar progesterona junto
com o estrogênio
vamos paraa próxima
pergunta Tiago 10 g de Glutamina por dia
é muito um tratamento de liqu gante cibo
Não não é muito não você pode começar
com 5 G por dia e depois aumentar como
você mesmo sugeriu aí dividir em duas
doses de manhã e e à noite ou à tarde tá
é tranquilo você usar a Glutamina na
dose mais alta porque pessoas vão ter
desconfortos gastrointestinais usando a
Glutamina na faixa de 10 g não é muito
não não é exagerado
tá e doses mais al vão ser mais eficazes
nação do intestino na melhora dos
sintomas cibo e vai dar maior suporte
imunológico
também agora algumas pessoas podem ter
gases tá ou diarreia mas é raro isso
acontecer com glutamina
uso indevido de prata pode gerar
resistência bacteriana então quando eu
estudei ess assunto alguns anos atrás
ideia é que a prata não tinha como os
microrganismos desenvolverem mecanismos
de defesa contra ela foi isso que eu
estudei na época tá quando eu fiz os
vídeos sobre prata coloidal Agora eu
achei material achei literatura dizendo
que já foram identificadas bactérias
resistentes à
prata então elas poderiam a desenvolver
resistência a partir de mecanismos de
chamad de
efluxo tem alguns genes nas bactérias
que conseguem espelir essa
prata e que também foram identificados
genes de resistência à prata que podem
ser transferidos de uma bactéria para
outra através de plasmídeos que é um
tipo de mecanismo de comunicação entre
bactérias tá que passa gênes de uma
bactéria para
outra então isso me surpreendeu na
verdade existe sim esse mecanismo de
resistência bacteriana à prata mas eu
acredito que ele seja muito mais paro do
que o mecanismo de resistência
bacteriana aos antibióticos tá entre
antibiótico e prata eu utilizaria a
prata se fosse
possível Boa noite Quais são os
marcadores íos para verificar a função
renal geralmente creatinina não é
creatina é creatinina e ureia tá o
senhor usa a taxa de filtração
glomerular estimada hoje a maioria dos
laboratórios já colocam isso
automaticamente eu não precisa nem pedir
o cálculo é complicado de ser feito tá
não vou nem apresentar para vocês aqui a
fórmula porque é uma fórmula bem
complicadinha tá não mas você pode dar
uma pesquisada na internet se você tiver
interesse tem um site chamado wolfran
Alfa você consegu fazer cálculos
matemáticos complicados Inclusive tem um
Plugin do Wolf alpa no chat APT caso
você tenha interesse
eh grande nesse assunto aí
tá mas é basicamente creatinina ureia e
a taxa de filtração glomerular estimada
os laboratórios do dia já dão para você
automaticamente não precisa nem fazer o
cálculo mas Mas podem ter erros tá por
exemplo se a pessa tiver se a pessoa
tiver ingerindo muita proteína ou
creatina pode aumentar a creatinina no
na urina e não ser necessariamente uma
insuficiência renal tá então tem que
tomar cuidado com esses exames aqui
alguns casos tem que pedir a taxa de
filtração glomerular real né que é o o
clearance de
creatinina qual seria o melhor para
diminuir resistência à insulina bieron
ou gluc
ventage pergunta muito boa também até
difícil de responder eu utilizaria a
princípio a
berberina e em alguns casos se a
berberina não resolver eu associaria a
metiformina na verdade a beberina
metformina tem mecanismo de ação muito
parecidos com a m da MPK eles são bem
semelhantes assim o mecanismo de ação só
que a beberina também tem um pouco mais
de ação no microbioma intestinal e
desses aí que você tá mostrando tanto o
bieron que é uma forma aí de auto
absorção da beberina quanto o glucovance
são bons mas aparentemente aí não tenho
certeza fica difícil comparar
diretamente mas Aparentemente o gluc
ventage é melhor porque a de
hidrobel isso potencial Desculpa poten
potencializaria os efeitos
tá e e é uma forma mais tolerada do que
a beberina comum então tanto o bieron
quanto o gluc vantage são bons mas
Aparentemente o glucanas eh ele é um
pouquinho melhor do que o
bieron Mas isso não é certeza
absoluta qual seria o melhor para
diminuir resistência na tá repetida a
pergunta Vamos pro próximo a semaglutida
manipulada e comprimidos também tem os
efeitos colaterais do osque eu acho que
você talvez a pergunta melhor seja se
semaglutida manipulada e comprimidos
teri os mesmos efeitos colaterais
do ribelo que é a forma oral do oque tá
eu não recomendo que nesse momento vocês
manipulem semaglutida tá eu acredito que
não é tão eficaz assim o manipulado eu
utilizaria mesmo o remédio original que
é o ribus
tá ele tem uma eficácia semelhante ao
ozic injetável na prática Clínica porém
o ozen pic injetável ele é mais
eficiente do que o rsus só que tem essa
facilidade aí do uso oral né o ribel mas
eu não utilizaria por enquanto
manipulado tá teve uma empresa que me
abordou dizendo que estavam fazendo
implante de ozic tá eu fiz um teste para
esse implante e ele não funcionou então
cuidado com
esse princípio ativo No momento eu não
recomendo que vocês manipulem tá não tá
confiável ainda no
momento Elian É verdade comer tâmaras em
jejum é uma forma natural de acabar com
vmes e parasitas não eu não recomendo
que você utilize a
Tâmara tá até porque a tâmera você vai
conseguir ela na forma de fruta
seca né E ela tem um alto índice
glicêmica nessa forma de fruta
seca eu utilizaria semente de mamão para
esse objetivo seu aí não semente de m
nem e não Tâmara Ok semente de mamão e
não
Tâmara e alimentos como alho cebola
gengibre e sementes de abóbora também
são citados como tendo propriedades
antiparasitárias Ok então alho cebola
gengibre e Semente de abóbora e semente
de
mamão Marilda Qual a diferença entre
ressonância magnética multiparamétrica
de próstata e ressonância prostática e
classificação de risco pad não é a mesma
coisa na verdade o pad é uma
classificação não é o exame tá quando
você faz uma ressonância magnética
multiparamétrica de próstata você pode
através desse exame
eh através de um radiologista que a
Trein você chegar com a classificação de
risco pades a classificação pades não é
um exame é simplesmente uma avaliação
que o radiologista faz em cima da imagem
da ressonância tá deu para entender a
diferença Marilda se você tiver ao vivo
podemos conversar mais a respeito Tá
então pirads não é um exame pirads é uma
classificação que você pode fazer a
partir de um exame que no caso é
ressonância magnética de pró
multiparamétrica Qual é o exame que mede
o volume da próstata ultrassom mede
volume ressonância mede volume tá eh mas
obviamente não vai pedir só uma você não
vai pedir uma ressonância só para ver
volume então você pode pedir um trra de
próstata via abdominal e se você quiser
ter mais precisão você pode pedir
ultrassom de próstata transretal que vai
ver melhor ainda o
volume quando na Live passada perguntei
o que se pode concluir quando existe uma
grande oscilação nos valores de PSA
discrimine os valores não tive a
intenção de pôr exames em análise Sim
apenas quis relacionar aos valores de
PSA e PSA livre para tentar entender o
que originaria uma relação percentual
tão oscilatória eh que aumentou 6% em 1
ano caiu que 5% no final de 19 meses
seguintes num paciente que tem 70 anos
então uma oscilação no PSA pode ser
várias coisas pode ser trauma pode ser
infecção de próstata com prostatite que
ele teve e aumentou o PSA depois ele
melhorou da prostatite e o PSA caiu tá
pode ter andado de a cavalo pode ter
andado a de moto né são coisas que
aumentam o PSA bom geralmente quando o
PSA Fica oscilando para cima e para
baixo é mais infecção isso daí então
mais provável que seja um
prostatite o que ocasiona um aumento PSA
livre Então o PSA Total
eh e o PSA livre são critérios que a
gente utiliza quando você tem um PSA
entre 4 e 10 tá que é uma faixa de zona
cinzenta quando tá o PSA entre 4 e 10 se
você utiliza a relação e se a relação
tiver abaixo de
18% Isso significa que a chance de ser
um câncer de PR maior tá Então na
verdade quando você tem essa relação
diminuída entre PS total e livre é uma
sugestão de de câncer de próstata Ok
para isso que a gente utiliza esse esse
critério aí
O que significa quando um PSA Total cai
três pontos em 19 meses mas a relação
entre PSA livre e Total também
reduz tá Eu já falei da questão da
prostatite mas a pergunta Tá um pouco
confusa então a gente Analisa isso tá se
o p tiver entre 4 e 10 e a relação tiver
abaixo de 8% isso aumenta o risco de ser
um câncer tá fica com isso na cabeça não
tenta complicar demais a pergunta porque
aí não não fica uma pergunta tão
coerente assim
tá pergunta da
Eliseu Qual é o nome do exame para saber
se eu tenho boas quantidades de DH a DH
sulfatado tá melhor exame mais confiável
do que o DH simples
Ahã ao fazer o exame de dha qual deve
ser o resultado para confirmar as
quantidades ideais acima de 150 tá entre
150 e 300 mais ou menos o dha ass
sulfatado você disse no vídeo que o DGA
não é liberado pela Anvisa para vender
em fá e manipulação é com esse nome não
tá mas agora é liberado já tem uns 2
anos ou dois ou TR anos com o nome prac
serona tá mas não com o nome dhe Mas é a
mesma coisa qual que é a dose de dhe por
dia por volta de 10 mg para mulher e
entre 20 e 50 mg para homem suplemento
dhe deve ser tomado longe das afeições
Não não precisa não vai atrapalha
absorção
não o site que vende dhea tem um
chama-se tem vários que vend aí o último
que eu ouvi falar era loja Maromba tá
você tem esse nome esse nome engraçado
aí mas é é o nome da loja loja Maromba
procura no Google você vai achar eles
vendem o dhea
tá há um ano você disse no YouTube que
carboidratos complexo
de qualidade aumentam a testosterona e
logo em seguida você citou exemplos de
que maneira a batata doce aumenta a
testosterona os carboidratos de digestão
lenta de modo geral aumentam a
testosterona dando substratos pro corpo
produzir a testosterona tá o problema da
aveia é que ela atrapalha a absorção dos
outros nutrientes confere que outros
nutrientes Eliseu você TNA lista o arroz
integral É verdade que o arroz integral
é pior que o arroz branco não não é pior
Ele é parecido em relação a índice
glicêmico a Mas ele tem mais nutrientes
arroz branco não aumenta a
testosterona não a quinoa que você citou
pode ser quinou em flocos pode é verdade
que quinou em grãos pode cozinhar fritar
que não perde nutriente nenhum que eu
saiba não perde nutriente tá uma colher
de sopa de Quino em floc potencializa o
efeito do suplemento creatina não não
potencializa o efeito do creatina
não tomar vinagre de maçã e beberina não
ao mesmo tempo mas juntas podem ser
prejudicial Não não é prejudicial não
Antônio câimbra no braço e perda de
força no braço de uma mulher diabética
está tomando beberina mas não faz uma
boa dieta é perigoso ela está iniciando
caminhada todos dias pode
ajudar se a cvra é
perigosa pode ser tem que ser tem que
ser avaliada por médico não dá para
responder aqui isso não viu Antônio tá
muito vago isso aqui para poder
responder tá bom tem que ser analisada
leva logo no médico para analisar essa P
de força no prç Pode até ser um AVC isso
daí
tá caminhar 4,6 KM e de volta é
suficiente para saúde de uma forma geral
sim é suficiente
sim é um é um bom trajeto se você fizer
todo dia tá O Suficiente
[Música]
sim qual a minha opinião sobre uma
refeição que tem amêndoas castanha do
Pará Caju Baru nós pecã velan pistache
semente de girassol Covo manteiga e
Flora Nil
Acho ótimo acho uma refeição excelente
tem vários nutrientes aqui nessa
refeição né inclusive paraa saúde
cerebral Acho ótimo também é muito bom
paraa saúde cardiológica isso aqui
tá com as enchentes no Rio Grande do Sul
Pode ser que falte arroz por isso minha
família comprou arroz Só que no entanto
meu pai pesquisou e comprou arroz branco
supostamente é melhor no quesito
preservação morora a estragar qual sua
opinião numa emergência se você quer
estocar arroz para por exemplo você
acredita que pode ter
uma crise muito grande que pode ter um
um colapso social como muita gente
acredita que possa acontecer faz mais
sentido você realmente armazenar o arroz
branco tá numa caso no caso de uma
emergência tá eh o Ross branco é melhor
ou pior do que o parborizado
não acho que eles são equivalentes tá
não vejo muita diferença entre os dois
não o pizado é ele ele gruda menos
né tá vamos ver as perguntas aqui ao
vivo Raí de Ortiga bloqueia aromatização
de testosterona tem tem um efeito sim
leve de bloqueio de aromatização
será que isso não é a causa das novas
carnes que querem que venhamos
comer sim eles utilizam o o argumento
que a carne vermelha faz mal para
empurrar essa agenda de comer carne
artificial concordo com
você é verdade que no Brasil aceita 20%
em todos os azeites
embalados eu não entendi essa pergunta
aceit o quê 20% do
quê Eu recomendo todas as marcas de de
bons produtores né de Portugal da
Espanha da do
Chile da Grécia da Turquia da Itália tá
eh agora não entendi sua pergunta Tá
miquinha sim eu recomendo essa marca
esporão é uma boa marca
prona para quem não tem útero pode ser
tomar todos os dias sem interromper pode
não tem problema nenhum
tá o tempo de validade que eu saiba
prata coloidal não tem um tempo de
validade específico não ele não vence tá
TAM
miquinha androgel É sim é bioidêntico
sim é testosteron na
base o vídeo que mandou assistirmos tem
alguma tem algum lugar nos recomendaria
que vídeo não tô entendendo Que vídeo é
esse que você tá
falando 20% de óleo de soja tá agora
entendi não não é verdade que todo o
azeite de oliva tem 20% de óleo de soja
não tá É só você você Alê o rótulo se
for um azeite extra virgem não tem nada
de óleo de
soja aquele vídeo que você colocou no
grupo eu vi eliz ele faz todo sentido tá
não compraria nenhum tipo de o quebrada
não ele tem razão a da a gordura da das
oleaginosas se for empacotada a vácuo é
mais confiável sim com
certeza eh oag genosa oxida se ficar em
contato com o ar durante Quanto tempo
mais de TRS
dias sim já respondi isso aqui
não sei dizer
eu dos que estão ao vivo assistindo
ah das perguntas que eu respondi do
documento ficou alguma dúvida das
respostas quem tá ao vivo e que também
fez pergunta no documento tem alguma
dúvida
Antônio Renato eu fiz uma pergunta agora
no documento você tá falando Ah sim já
vi que tem mais uma pergunta aqui se uma
pessoa está deixa eu colocar na
tela se uma pessoa está prestes a ter
uma AVC a caminhada ou exercício em alta
intensidade pode ajudar a
evitar não vai ajudar a evitar a longo
prazo mas não se a pessoa tá tendo uma
crise naquele exato
momento tá então se você fizer caminhada
a longo prazo obviamente vai te proteger
Mas se a pessoa tiver a um passo de ter
um AVC não adianta pô ela para correr
que não vai evitar o AVC não sei se é
isso que você quis
dizer
tá todas as oleaginosas ficam macias
quando
oxidadas
ã Quais são os sinais de
oxidação não não acho que seja visível
sinais de oxidação não Eliseu talvez se
que mole mesmo como você tá falando mas
não é não conheço outro sinal além desse
não
oleaginosas guardadas na geladeira tem
algum problema não não
tem não a cândida não vai morrer com a
com a com a temperatura da geladeira não
não é confiável esse método aí não viu
Eliseu
não o plástico Ele tá em todos os
lugares né elizu O ideal seria não
utilizar por causa dos produtos aí
derivados do plásticos que são Chen
estrógenos mas
eh entre os males o menor é muito mais
muito melhor você lidar com isso do que
ter um problema de contaminação aí de de
fungo
né Não não é comum ter agrotóxico em
olear genosa não
não é um um um produto especialmente
rico em agrotóxico Que eu saiba não
Eliseu bem pessoal Estamos indo para 45
minutos de Live né até para ficar mais
fácil para vocês verem os vídeos depois
eu eu não gosto de estender demais essas
lives
Tá eu vou ficar mais um minuto para
responder dúvidas de
vocês obrigado Eliseu pelo
feedback Antônio Renato tem alguma
dúvida TAM miquinha Carlos kman que
deixou Pergunta lá no
questionário Denise Eloí alguém com mais
alguma
dúvida Obrigado Tami quinha
pelo boa noite bom descanso também para
você e para todos que estão assistindo a
Live Então pessoal vou encerrar Tá bom
já que não tem mais dúvidas e agradeço
novamente tem uma dúvida última aqui do
Eliseu Mas agradeço novamente aí a
audiência de
vocês não essa aqui Eu já
respondi já te falei que o agrotóxico
não é um problema pro pras oleaginosas
[Música]
tá boa noite a todos um grande abraço a
todos vocês até a próxima semana um
beijo no coração